regardez juste la monty cadre des 100000
a éclairci le studio pour l'instant il
est là il changera peut-être plus tard
bon voilà c'est pas à l'ordre du jour
bref aujourd'hui on parle de cette
montre c'est la ouate j'étais alors elle
est pas toute neuve a été présenté
l'année dernière fin d'année 2010 et moi
je et le stade est aujourd'hui donc je
suis très content de pouvoir la tester
cette jolie petite montre les grosses
boîtes sympa cette world gtl à des
points qui sont vraiment positifs
elle a aussi des trucs un petit peu hâlé
limitatif s'affairer à l'est c'est
dommage surtout vu le prix
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va faire
un tour complet je voudrais c'est les
points très positifs de cette montre
vous dire ce que j'aimerais voir évoluer
et qui pourra l'être parce qu'on parle
vraiment de logiciels de ça vous avez le
vent dans quelques instants et puisse
compter sur vous pour me dire à ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire et dès
maintenant s'ils voulaient pouvaient
déjà les singes ou les pouces punta
plaisir et bien évidemment vous abonner
go
[Musique]
en fait cette montre elle a été
présentée en même temps que le mail
20h20 trop fin d'année dernière
donc je vous avais peut-être déjà
entendu parler si c'est le cas dit que
moi moi je la trouve vraiment cool si ce
n'est j'ai bien transpiré je les dis à
mouiller que mais rassurez-vous
allaitantes jusqu'à 50 mètres donc ça
sera plutôt pas mal on va commencer par
le design moi j'aime bien cette montre
c'est l'intérêt en tout cas est ce que
je reproche souvent des mondes si vous
n'avez pas des vrais bracelet là vous
avez un vrai bracelet vous fermez vous
le mettez dans ses pratiques
ça ne vous arrache pas l'épaule de tous
les côtés ça c'est plutôt bien on ici
sur un bracelet en silicone mais vous
pouvez changer peut aussi mettre si vous
souhaitez un bracelet en cuir comme vous
voulez vous n'êtes très facilement à le
remplacer ça c'est plutôt cool
une autre se trouve sympa je trouve ça
vraiment très sympa d'un point de vue
matériaux vous avez dû céramique vous
avez de l'acier inoxydable pour le
boîtier vous avez un écran amoled
complètement tactile de 1,39 pouces 454
par 454 pixels c'est vraiment là une des
grosses qualités en tout cas de ce
produit c'est cet écran qui est vraiment
de qualité qui est très bon en pleine
luminosité vous le mettez dehors il ya
du soleil ça marche c'est cool donc ça
c'est vraiment aussi un point très
positif au point qui est assez positif
c'est que je trouve quand même
relativement légère donc ça c'est pareil
à votre poignet vous allez pas avoir
comme espèce de doute voilà ça se tient
bien c'est léger c'est pratique c'est
sympa ce qui est vraiment bien avec
cette mort et wad gt c'est l'autonomie
et s'assure ça cool je lai à mon bras je
la remets le matin je pose pas la
question est-ce qu'elle va décharger de
ce qu'elle tient une semaine ça s'est
vraiment bien et en plus autre point qui
est vraiment cool c'est que vouloir
changer bien évidemment comme ça c'est
aimante et sa très facilement et en plus
vous venez vous avez un petit bloc de
recharge en usb c'est alors vous avez un
cap qui fournit avec usb usb sais mais
c'est vraiment cool d'avoir de l'usb
c'est sûr pour recharger une bombe comme
ça donc ça aussi
point positif maintenant il ya un point
un peu négatif avec cette montre c'est
son stockage vous avez 16 méga de ram et
128 megas de stockage autant dire que
vous ne mettez pas de musique à
l'intérieur vous ne pouvez rien stocker
vous êtes vraiment limité de ce côté
négatif c'est que vous n'allez pas
pouvoir rajouter
non plus d'applications je vous parlais
l'ol dans quelques instants on est sur
un os propriétaire mail est strictement
impossible de racheter les applications
n'y a pas de catalogue d'applications
saas est pour moi un point c'est
limitative parce que lorsque par exemple
vous partez courir et que vous voulez
par smartphone avec vous voulez
l'utiliser pour mettre de la musique de
danse et bien c'est pas possible
vous ne pouvez pas stocker quoi que ce
soit à l'intérieur par contre ce qui est
cool c'est que vous avez du gps à
l'intérieur vous n'avez pas que du gps
vous avez aussi galileo
vous n'avez glonass enfin le truc est
cool c'est que quel que soit l'endroit
où vous êtes sur terre vous savez que
votre monde va pouvoir se repérer vous
allez pouvoir aller courir
elle sera toujours allez donc ça plutôt
bien en plus ce qui est bien c'est que
vous avez un suivi de rythme cardiaque
est la fonction du de l'écran sur lequel
vous êtes né pouvoir paramétrer votre
écran 10 pour me garder le même
eh bien vous avez toujours avoir votre
écran de rythme cardiaque qui va
s'afficher
moi j'ai choisi celui-là bleu foncé je
trouve sympa voyez 74 bpm
mais surtout je pouvais revenir dans mes
applications je vais dans rythme
cardiaque et là je vais pouvoir
retrouver mon rythme cardiaque avec un
vrai historique
je tapais au plus vite à 118 au plus bas
à 64 et après voyez en règle générale au
repos à 65 bps
par contre un truc qui est vachement
bien si vous avez une application c'est
l'application santé ou là vous allez
pouvoir retrouver toutes vos infos là
par exemple j'ai mon rythme cardiaque
dont ça c'est aujourd'hui je vais voir
ma semaine avec toutes mes infos voyez
quand j'ai battu au plus bas est au plus
haut et la voyage quelques infos plage
de rythme cardiaque rythme cardiaque
moyens au repos au rythme cardiaque
élevé bon il faut croire qu'il était
levé 165 caillebot c'était quand même
plutôt pas mal et après il faut journée
mois année puisqu'on n'en est plus un
pouvoir regarder vous avez toutes vos
questions de sommeil question de poids
vous pouvez venir entre et l'historique
des exercices c'est pas trop mon cas
parce que je suis pas trop un sportif
j'ai mon nom de pas nombre de pas
aujourd'hui la distance donc de qui ou
calories brûlées estimé enfin il ya
quand même pas mal de choses qu'on peut
venir voir dans cette appli il ya aussi
une partie exercice et où votre profil
entre avoir toqué quand même assez sympa
puisqu'on est sur leur s on va en parler
d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle parce que
je suppose que vous avez suivi tous les
déboires qui est entre la chine et
notamment huawei qui en a fait les frais
et les états unis donald trump le fait
que huawei se placer sur la liste noire
des entreprises avec lesquelles on ne
puisse pas travailler lorsqu'il est
débloqué ils sont toujours sur la liste
mais maintenant on peut travailler avec
offres historiques tels assez
hallucinant qu'est ce qui est d'ailleurs
très intéressant très rigolo c'est que
dans cette montre là vous n'avez pas
ouvert os donc vous n'avez pas d'eau et
ce qui appartient à google comment
retrouver sur beaucoup de monde connecté
là vous avez
reste propriétaire de huawei qui
s'appelle light os c'était très drôle
est ce qu'il fait sourire justement
c'est que on voit que les problèmes
qu'il y a eu entre huawei et les
etats-unis ont fait que huawei ne
souhaite plus avoir de licence google et
ne pouvait donc plus commerciale et
google peut plus travailler les google
et donc dans les smartphone huawei il
aurait pu arriver si ça avait continué
mais ce qui n'est pas le cas il aurait
pu arriver qu'on est plus du tout
d'android
même si aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'assez
en tout cas mener huawei sur la
direction de se dire de toute façon va
falloir qu'on trouve une solution pour
ne pas dépendre à tel point des états
unis d'une entreprise tierce
donc je pense que à l'avenir ça va
emmener au wawel justement à avoir son
propre os à voir comment les choses se
mettre en place
et c'est justement très drôle que
quelques mois auparavant et s'est sorti
non connectés avec leurs propres os et
non pas webos alors couvert ou est quand
même un peu plus ouvert avec plus de
possibilités mais bon en tout cas c'est
nouvelle s'appelle light os il ya des
choses qui sont pas encore complètement
génial sur la lecture des notifications
notamment des sms
il ya des choses à améliorer mais en
tout cas ça c'est encourageant
par contre il y avait quelques pas qui
sont ces négatifs notamment le fait de
ne pas pouvoir répondre aux sms
directement à partir de votre montre pas
y avoir message qu'ils soient pré
définis à taper envoyé non plus le
consulter et ensuite il faut aller sans
vos smartphones pour faire le reste la
même chose pour les appels téléphoniques
mais surtout le point qu'il plus
bloquants est vraiment problématique là
dessus c'est comme je disais tout à
l'heure comme vous n'avez pas de
possibilité de stockage ne pouvait pas
rajouter des applications terre s'il n'y
a pas de magasin d'applications sur
light os donc vous ne pouvez pas venir
chercher des applications
diverses et variées venir hershey dans
votre monde et c'est un petit peu pour
moi le problème principal
vous allez acheter non connectés de
lâcheté du monde de saint cloud nous
épargner pas entendre la samsung galaxy
watch active et vous avez un catalogue
vous pouvez devenir télécharger
différentes applications autant vous
voulez tant que vous pouvez en tout cas
en mètre à l'intérieur et là c'est pas
possible
et je trouve que c'est vraiment le gros
point négatif de cette montre même si
vous n'avez pas toutes vos applications
directement dans votre montre et bien
vous pouvez choisir ce que vous allez
envoyer de votre téléphone directement à
votre montre et ça c'est plutôt bien
c'est vraiment tout ce que je trouve
intéressant voir par exemple ici j'ai
toutes les notifications que j'ai
autorisé donc mon agenda c'est ma voix
mais rappelle d'agenda facebook les
notifications l'objet de mon email et
qui lui envoyait mais seul un joli
message voix les sms twitter ouah de sa
perf en bref donc j'ai ce genre de
choses que vous pouvez aussi tout venir
ajouté auxquelles certaines applications
qui sont pas forcément très intéressante
mais dans l'absolu mais je pouvais pas
cette application il ya vous avez comme
l accès à toutes ces applications grâce
aux notifications de vos smartphones
donc ça c'est quand même un petit peu
moindre mal par contre c'est quand même
pas mal de choses qui sont disponibles
directement dans votre monde pour le
sport vous pouvez choisir le sport vous
voulez faire un mois je ne suis pas
particulièrement sportif donc j'utilise
pas mais c'est vrai que voyez entre la
course d'idées qu'on s'extasie leur
course intérieure marche en extérieur la
randonnée la course en cross country et
je ne connaissais pas voyez cycliques
semaine 6 ou 7 du real ya ceci n'est pas
un film sur le cyclisme le cyclisme
extérieur cycliste intérieur najat
ailleurs linge extérieur triathlon par
la banque va quand même pas mal de
choses et ça bon vous avez quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités alors puisqu'on
est là on va les voir un peu au niveau
des les applications qui sont déjà pré
installé toute la partie effectivement
entraînement dont je viens de vous
parler à l'instant on pouvait retrouver
directement ici votre historique statut
de formation au rythme cardiaque
l'activité vous avez fait aujourd'hui ce
que vous avez fait non de pas le cl ça
vous avez tous directement ici puis du
sommeil alors moi je n'arrive pas à
dormir avec une montre au poignet mais
gallas pas qu'ils y arriveront ils le
font déjà
vous avez donc un suivi de votre cycle
de sommeil avec les différentes parties
de votre site c cool baromètre boussole
météo les messages chronomètre minuterie
alarme lampe de poche trouvé mon
téléphone et la configuration voyez donc
ça c'est sympa mais par contre c'est
quand même assez limité lorsque vous
naviguez retrouver si votre suivi
d'activité la météo ici
votre rythme cardiaque vous retrouvez là
on bat les messages
ici on n'a pas bien voyez-vous tournant
donc vous allez à droite ou à gauche
c'est exactement la même chose l'écran
principal vous descendez vous avez votre
petit raccourci montrer leur ne pas
déranger trouvé mon téléphone est
verrouillé
et puis la configuration pour moi c'est
très clair qu'une boîte comme huawei va
pas se contenter de proposer cet os là
avec juste cette possibilité là c'est
une première version c'est une première
nation qui est encourageante il va y
avoir une évolution au niveau de l'ouest
va y avoir plus de choses de proposer là
c'est déjà assez complète ehr c'est une
montre qui vous servira vraiment pour
l'exercice physique et ça marche plutôt
bien moi ça fait une bonne semaine que
j'utilise je suis con qui se trouve
vraiment intéressante mais il ne faut
pas chercher à aller au delà que ce
qu'elle vous propose
il faut accepter ses limites acceptées
ses défauts mais par contre en
contrepartie vous avez vraiment belle
qualité et justement notamment au niveau
de l'autonomie
à savoir également d'enseignement de
vous avez du bluetooth 4 points 2 vous
n'avez pas bien et c'est donc il n'y
aura pas de paiement dématérialisé avec
votre montre après je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui sont des usages qui sont
extrêmement répandu ça commence à se
faire avec le smartphone avec la montre
est ce que ça c'est beaucoup
pas nécessairement mais en tout cas ça
évolue donc dans les années à venir il
va falloir pouvoir l'intégrer
il n'y a effectivement pas de wifi et
vous ne pouvez pas non plus avoir de
carte sim à l'intérieur donc vous ne
pouvez pas l'utiliser de façon 100 %
indépendante pour passer des coups de
fil toute façon l'om ne vous le permet
pas elle est résistante à l'eau comme
vous lisez jusqu'à 50 mètres donc si
vous aimez huawei si vous trouvez cette
montre intéressant et bien je dirais que
dès lors que vous connaissez un petit
peu ses défauts et bien évidemment ses
qualités et vous allez accepter jo
d'aidé pour vous pouvez y aller je pense
qu'il va y avoir des belles évolutions
qui vont arriver dans les temps à venir
de la part de huawei j'imagine qu'ils
vont continuer à avancer justement au
niveau du r&b au niveau de ses montres a
qui sont vraiment très sympa dans la
mesure vous voulez une montre que vous
voulez juste ce soir vos notifications
que vous n'avez pas besoin d'envoyer des
sms d'appeler pas besoin de stocker de
la musique à l'intérieur des nouveaux
lieux monde connecté sympa résistante
robuste elle la gueule si elle vous fait
de l'oeil pour moi on pouvait y aller en
plus en ce moment il ya des tarifs
préférentiels ses intérêts si vous êtes
tous mis en bas dans la description
pouvez y aller c'est une jolie mais
c'est un joli produit
je trouve vraiment intéressant surtout
très surpris par l'autonomie et ça pour
moi c'est vraiment énorme alors je pense
que justement cette autonomie on l'a
aussi parce que c'est un petit peu plus
fermé parce qu'on n'a pas pleins
d'applications qui vont travailler en
tâche de fond et qui dut couvre plus
énergivore donc le point négatif
vous donne aussi du positif donc je
trouve quand même au final plutôt
intéressante le tarif me semble un peu
élevé
vu la concurrence 249 euros je lis mon
père gardé par les liens parce qu'il ya
quand même des promotions ça c'est
plutôt cool
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez cette fois wiiware
gt il existe plusieurs versions moi j'ai
l'activé édition n en 46 mm je trouve
cool je trouve sympa juste très content
pour la porte au poignet et c'est une
honte que je porte vraiment avec plaisir
et en plus ya de jolis finition regarder
au niveau du bracelet là il est bien
écrit watts j'étais à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas un commentaire
si ça vous intéresse est ce que vous
avez une monde connecté si oui laquelle
et est ce que vous pourriez aller sur
une montre de huawei et puis pourquoi
pas cette web j'étais à vous de jouer
vous marrer tout semblant commentaires
validés évidemment a blessé des jolies
pousse à vous abonner et quand il
apparaît peut-être à demain ciao